NARRATOR: Auckland,
Retired military and commercial
airline pilot, Bruce Cathie,
publishes his book,
"The Energy Grid."
In it, he details his
experience observing
refers during his time working
for the New Zealand military.
He noted that these
crafts were always
following straight lines.
After mapping them, he
discovered that they followed
a distinctive grid pattern.
Additionally, while flying
over some of these zones,
he also noticed that various
structures were actively
being built along the paths.
DAVID CHILDRESS: Bruce
Cathie maintained
that the American military,
starting in World War II,
had also figured out
this special grid that
surrounds the entire planet.
And that the military
was using certain spots
on the earth to build military
bases and other structures.
NARRATOR: Cathy suggested that
the extraterrestrial craft
may have been drawing
power off the grid.
And that after World War II
and the Roswell incident,
military personnel
around the world
had become aware of
this UFO connection.
DAVID CHILDRESS: So here we
have an ancient grid structure,
probably built by
extraterrestrials, possibly
to power their craft that's
now being reconstructed today
by the military.
NARRATOR: Could it be
that ancient structures
throughout the
world were designed
to function together as part
of a massive energy grid?
And did the architects
intentionally leave
behind information
for us to find
once we had the
technological knowledge
to recognize the system?
But why?
What were the alien
architects trying to tell us?
GIORGIO TSOUKALOS:
Extraterrestrials
knew that at some
point in our evolution,
a technologically advanced
society would stumble
across all of
these ancient sites
and see their correlation,
thus forcing us to take
into consideration that some
type of extraterrestrials
showed our ancestors where
to build these things, not
for them, but for us.
DAVID WILCOX: The grid
itself may, in fact,
be a source of
unconventional energy
that we are not necessarily
utilizing with our technology
now.
And advanced, intelligent
race wanted to leave something
behind for us to
discover that would give
us the clues to a
greater level of science
than we now understand.
WILLIAM HENRY: It could be that
this master architect sought
not only to influence
the earth, but also
to connect the
earth to something
greater or beyond
our imagination.
Perhaps this grid even
extends out into the stars
and the world grid of the
earth connects with the grip
of other planets as well.
And that integrates the
Earth into a huge colony,
if you will, or integrated
circuit throughout the cosmos.